Good morning everyone.
Welcome to our session here. We're here to talk
about, uh, how you can protect your data
and secure your data for AI workloads in particular
using tokenization.
In the next 45 minutes or so,
uh, we're gonna talk about one of the biggest
fiction points facing enterprises today,
which is around how to secure
your data and at the same time make
it useful for your AI workloads
and analytic workloads.
Um, we will also talk through how
we navigated this journey at Capital One
and share some of these learnings, um.
And uh talk through some of your key takeaways
from those.
Um By
way of um introduction here, so my name
is Sukan Bankat. I'm part of the uh
product team here at Capital One Software,
and with me is my partner in Crime Binayak.
So we both will
talk through different parts of this. um, I will cover
some of the initial portion around motivation
for this as well as, um,
some of our
key learnings and then hand it off to and I
to wrap up the,
the blueprints and other parts of the presentation.
So here's a road map. Our agenda, so we'll
start with what we call the
um
AI data dilemma. Essentially we'll start
by defining what
the industry-wide challenge we face today
around fueling AI
uh with sensitive data without compromising
the utility of the data
and compromising the security of the data.
Um, in the second part we'll cover
what is tokenization, how that can help with,
uh, maybe handling this
dilemma and, um, you know,
handling this sort of bottleneck that exists between the two.
Specifically, we'll talk about, uh, the format
preserving nature of, uh, tokenization,
uh, as one of the superior methods to encryption
or masking or other techniques for data protection.
Um, we'll round this out with the
Capital One case study where we'll talk about,
um, we'll sort of peel back the curtain
on how Capital One went through this journey, how
we, uh, built up our
product stack,
and, uh, how did we enforce this at,
uh, scale, um,
for that is, uh, demanded by our large
footprint.
Um, at the end of this, we'll also
share some learnings from this, some actionable
patterns that you can take and use today
for, uh, training LLMs or other models
and building AI guardrails, uh, with
this approach.
So with that let's uh kind
of talk through what what is this data
dilemma or data bottleneck that we see today.
uh, essentially what this is
is, uh,
the reality that a lot of us face today
with enterprise data. He is a top priority.
Over 70% of, uh, enterprises
today, um, have,
have the, uh.
Have projects that are centered around AI.
Almost everyone here in the room has
some AI project, uh, within your enterprise
that you're probably, uh,
looking to leverage data for.
Businesses are aggressively pursuing this AI
with 70% of this organizations listing,
uh, AI as the top, uh, one
of the top 5 investment areas
for accelerating, um, these coding
tasks, for example, um,
with your AI assistance or evolutionizing
your customer experience. Uh,
the potential for AI is huge, we
understand that,
but the value that you can get out of those AI
investments
depends on,
um, the value of the
quality and value and quality of the data
and completeness of the data that is used to train
these models and is used at inference time.
So as these AI models, uh,
we all know is data, they are all data hungry,
they need vast amounts of high quality
data
and high quality information to learn these patterns
and make predictions.
Um, significant portion of that is,
uh, includes sensitive data. So this could be your,
you know, uh, PII information, financial
records, health data.
And this creates a sort of a deadlock that
uh we want to kind of explore.
So you need this data to innovate,
but using that data
uh in the raw form creates massive risks, whether it's
from a compliance
or regulatory perspective.
Uh, the most predictive data that you might have
in your enterprise could, this could be transactions,
these could be health records, this could be personal
identifiers,
is also the most regulated and the most risky.
So for businesses this data is an asset
and it represents the insight, but for the
security teams it poses a problem. How
do we enable the secure, uh,
secure usage of this data, especially for AI
workloads,
and you can see here some more, uh, statistics around.
Uh, the prevalence of privacy regulations
that is, you know, uh, kind of exploded over the
past several years, and
then the number of data breaches. So these are stats
that, you know, I'm sure you've seen,
uh, across the industry.
The, the key part here is that this is
also linked to almost the, uh, tripling
of this data.
Over the past several years, uh, this is all
net new data that's been generated and how
do we now use this all responsibly
in, in our AI workloads for training
and inferncing purposes.
So that's, that's what we'll talk about through the
rest of this talk.
So our approach centers around, uh,
separating the,
uh,
this value from risk. So the idea here
being that we break the deadlock we're
changing how we view the data.
Uh, we need to support, uh, separate
the informational value of the data
from the risk that it poses and during use.
Uh, we, we sort of have this framework called
de-identify,
analyze, and unlock that, um,
you know, we found, uh, useful and, uh,
uh, when we talk about this at Capital One.
The first pillar of this is the de-identified
part. So we replace the sensitive data
with
with non-sensitive tokens
which ends up reducing the risk
and sometimes even neutralizing this risk.
So if the data gets compromised, the hackers steal
the data, you still are protected because
they've gained nothing of value. All of the data
still is non-sensitive and
can be safely used in in these
contexts.
The second part of this which is critical
is that. It needs to enable
your analytic use cases and your AI
training and other uh AI enabled workflows,
uh, for that
we need to preserve the format, we need to preserve
the statistical properties and other desirable
characteristics of the data and not lose
them as you desensitize this data
and this allows uh all of these
AI workloads and analytic engines
to run with very minor modifications
and uh
not use that utility of the data that we
had talked about.
Uh, through these, uh, techniques,
if the risk is virtually eliminated now
you can open the floodgates, you can freely use this,
uh, to train, use this data to, through your
AI data pipelines for model training,
decision making, etc.
So that's, that's the approach that we are advocating
for and then we'll see how
Keplerman worked through this journey and, um, talk
through some of our
learnings from there.
So, uh,
I wanna kind of take a step back and when we talk
about protecting data,
um, there is a spectrum, um,
of of of this landscape of data protection,
uh, that you see out here.
So on the left you have methods like your deletion,
masking, reduction. These are typically
non-reversible. There are some cases where,
uh, there's some reversible masking that has been
attempted
and they are the key part here is that they are
somewhat destructive to the utility of the data.
So they're great for reducing the risk,
but they also compromise the,
the utility of your data. So as an
example, you can't train your models, AI models
on deleted data. You, you can't train them
on partially massed data
where only let's say, uh, part of
your strings are available, part of your numbers are available,
um, in, in, in, in the form that
is desensitized.
So let's, uh, kind of look at this landscape,
uh, through this lens. So say I mask a
credit card number to reveal only the last four digits.
I've secured the data, but at the same time I've now
compromised the utility of the data, so I can't
train a fraud model,
uh, where I only know the last four digits and I
can't analyze those spending patterns. It's
safe, but it's not useful. So
how do we sort of, you know, overcome this is
through the other two methods that you see on the right here. So
on the right we have those reversible methods
where, uh, with encryption or tokenization
we can, um,
reverse the process
and at the same time be able to preserve all of that analytic
value, um,
you know, is not lost in in the transformation.
Both allow you to get the original data back
if you, if, uh, the user and in
the context in which they're using it, it's authorized
and you also have access to other, you know, key
material and other things that we need to reverse the transformation
but there are critical differences between the two so
I wanna touch upon a couple of those and
then talk about why, uh, we went
down the tokenization path and,
um, how we sort of affected
that at Capital One.
So if you look at the.
Um, the key differences here,
traditional encryption deals with data
addressed, so it takes your, let's say your nine
digit social number, turns it into a string
of, um, alphanumeric or numeric
characters.
The problem is that.
Unless you're using a format preserving encryption,
um, it breaks your database schemas,
um, it breaks any validation logic,
and most importantly, your AI models
tend to be confused because they can no longer
see the shape and the characteristics of
the data.
Tokenization is
slightly different from this approach. So what
we do there is we replace this with
another similar
formatted string.
And it looks like a credit card number. It
passes the validation checks, etc.
It fits in, you know, with whatever the referential
integrity constraints you might have on your database
columns,
um, so.
To your applications, uh, whether
to be analytic applications or AI
models or pipelines, they did look, looks
real, but
to a bad actor it's meaningless. So even if it's compromised,
it is just a, uh, you know, bunch of
tokens that don't have any value or correlation
to the sensitive information.
So this format preservation length preservation,
all of these characteristics
allows us to secure the data in
use, not just at rest so you can
now do joints across columns and
and the magic key here for AI is that all of
these downstream applications
uh can now
literally consume this data and be able
to, you know,
provide the same level of accuracy and fidelity and we
we'll share some results around this, um, as
we talk this process.
So the, the concept is summarized
at the, uh, in the graphic below.
So you see, uh, uh, the
original Social Security number
is put through a tokenization engine
through APIs, etc.
and then out comes this string that is formatted
exactly like the original Social Security number with the
324 with dashes and we ran
them then that is how it's stored,
so it's stored as modified.
And um that makes it easier
for these uh business tools and others that are
using this to be able to utilize
that uh in the same fashion as they
were with the original data and then you can
now safely do your joints and preserve the analytic
values because uh
there's consistency in terms of that operation. So
if A goes to B somewhere, then A goes to B
everywhere that you see A in your data.
So that's the
uh value that you see here and that's one
of the reasons why we went with the tokenization approach
uh which is uh which we found is far
superior to any other uh
data protection techniques that we talked about.
So in particular what are the uh
key benefits that we get with uh
protecting your sensitive data using tokenization,
uh, beyond just the format preservation
of modern tokenization systems offer.
Sort of the security hygiene for the cloud.
So what we mean by that is,
uh, we have simplified key management. So we are
managing a key for every single read
operation like you would have to do with encryption,
and this becomes a huge bottleneck and the
performance, um, and, and brings
up latency and other issues that, uh, you'll
encounter with the whole, uh, encryption
space.
Uh, the second piece is around the referential integrity,
so the same input always gets the same
token. Uh, this means you can perform your
joints safely across different databases
using the tokens
without ever reversing that tokenization
process. The third piece that is also critical
here is that we embed
metadata,
um. Uh,
such as, you know,
versioning and other logic
inside of the token itself,
so this allows us to do key rotations,
uh, for example, and then, uh, the
system knows, uh, a priori
how to detokenize this based on the
token itself which allows us to do
this, uh.
Key rotation as well as excess any sort of,
you know, bad or compromised data
when that happens and then we can now
safely rotate this without touching the raw data
so this gives us a huge benefit in
terms of
management of this over time as as
changes happen.
The other two,
key pieces mentioned at the bottom here
are the preservation of the analytic value which
we already touched upon and
because of this, uh, the architecture of
this tokenization. Uh, solution
that we'll talk about,
uh, the brute force, key compromises,
um,
become virtually,
uh, infeasible. So we'll, we'll see how that
is possible with, uh, in the next
few slides.
OK, the other key question that you
might be wondering here
is,
Um
Data does the tokenization actually hurt
my model's performance? We did
a study and we'll be releasing the results of this
in the next couple of weeks,
um, where we did a study comparing
three sets of, uh, 3 data sets. So the
original raw clear text data.
Mass data and tokenized data and
we use those to train models
and then we saw a dramatic improvement
in performance with the tokenized data
so you see the, the red box that represents
uh the accuracy of the massed,
uh, the data using the mass uh the
models using the mass data
that drops it from
the clear text baseline of 100% to 50%
in the world of prediction, you know, 50%
is obviously not the greatest slick.
You know, just the same as a coin toss and
practically worthless.
On the other side, when we use tokenized data,
we were able to preserve,
uh, that accuracy. So 99%
of, uh, +% of the predictive accuracy
was, uh, retained with the clear stack
baseline data.
Um, so what this means is that you can now
train your models, um, on
safe compliant data and still
get the same results
that you would that are virtually identical to
training that on the raw sensitive
data. So you get nearly identical model
performance with virtually zero risk with
this. So that's why we went down this path
of, uh,
doing all of our data protection
anchoring on, on, uh, tokenization.
So, shifting gears a little bit, let's maybe
look at the concepts here.
So we looked at what tokenization
offers us.
Let's see how that is actually done in
practice. So
here's a little cartoon that explains this.
Um, so you'll see on the top here,
uh, so the sensitive data, this could be a Social Security
number that is being fed into your
applications, uh, the tokenization
engine, API or whatever you're using will
request uh token. So all of the
crypto material and all the magic with all the algorithms
behind the scenes will convert that, uh,
raw sensitive data into a token that
preserves the format and length, etc. and
then it returns that token that you see there starting with the
5C7.
And that data is now uh
stored in wherever your uh
data, wherever the original data sources, and
then the applications can now safely use that
proxy or the surrogate token wherever
the original data was needed
and because of its uh format preserving
link preserving all of these other characteristics we can now
use this
consistently across your entire landscape and you
won't lose any
referential integrity issues. You
won't run into this. But how do you actually implement
this in a modern cloud native
sort of environment.
And without,
uh, you know, grinding, bringing your
operations to a grinding halt.
So that's how
we want to talk about next in, in our case study
with Capital One.
So,
uh, our journey with tokenization
began, um,
around 2016. We were a traditional bank.
We had a lot of on-premise data centers
and lots of data over there,
but we made this very bold decision, um,
in 2016 to go all in on the cloud,
on the public cloud in particular.
By 2020 we had completed this transformation,
exited our data centers entirely,
and we were the first major bank, uh, to
do, do so.
But that migration
came with a sort of a little twist here,
so we had to move these petabytes of data
in, you know, highly sensitive financial data
into the cloud
and our old data security
approaches couldn't keep up
so they became bottlenecks for us. So how do,
how do we kind of, you know,
get, you know, get over this bottleneck?
Uh, we looked at a lot of, uh, technologies
out there, uh, did a.
A lot of evaluations of of these
uh and we found out that there's nothing that could
offer the performance and scale that we needed for
our data
so we ended up building our own
engine so
we built our own token tokenization engine from the ground up
and designed
it specifically for the elasticity
and other characteristics uh that
we needed in the cloud.
So that engine has become like the de facto standard
and core pillar of our data security across
Capital One today and it's like
it kind of underpins our entire data security strategy
at Capital One.
So we took these learnings and then
um
as a
we realized that hey.
There is a huge amount of value here
that can, you know, we can
give to other enterprises outside if we
share this technology, so we decided to productize
this through, uh, the Capital One
software entity that we founded
in 2022 and then we launched this product
as what we call, uh, as data board
in April 2025,
um, at the RSA conference earlier this year.
And this is what we will talk about in
the rest of this presentation of uh
how what the benefits are and how we, uh,
you know, what that has netted us and some
patterns that we've learned in the
usage of these kinds of technologies
in terms of securing data at scale with cloud
native uh environments.
So just to kind of give you a bit of context
on this, uh, the scale of this whole
tokenization engine and how it's used
at Capital One.
Um,
we protect
over 29 different types of sensitive elements,
everything from your Social Security numbers to dates
of birth or
custom, you know, customer account IDs, etc.
Over 900 applications, um,
all hitting this, you know, massive
tokenization infrastructure internally
and then billions of records
where, you know, across our enterprise that are,
um, used,
um, and then all of this is AWS native,
so when you operate at this scale,
um. We, you know, latency
is, uh, it's not just an annoyance, it
becomes a failure
of the design. So we've
very carefully architect this, uh, tokenization
engine to
really be very highly performing
and have very low latency.
So what this means is that.
As a digital bank
we really need to have a real-time highly
available fault tolerant service that
we can rely upon
to be able to do this. So that's, that's what,
uh, we've built and we'll talk through some
of the characteristics of this and
then I will do a deep dive into some of our learnings from
there and, and,
uh, how we can kind of, you know,
expand the footprint of these, uh, use cases
that we can address, especially from an AI perspective,
uh, with this
solution. OK,
so one of the key underpinnings of
our tokenization solution
um is the concept of a vaultless
tokenization.
Traditional tokenization approach you have relied
on a vault, which is a massive central
database which maps your sensitive
data to the tokens or the
proxies or surrogate values.
The problem
with this is that because it's a database,
it quickly becomes a bottleneck.
Every time you need,
every, every time you need a token, you have to
do a database lookup.
And because of that, it adds latency and
creates a single point of failure.
Um, and it also becomes a massive
attack vector for your, uh,
hackers. In fact, your
vault becomes a honey pot. So if a
hacker breaches this
database, they have keys to the entire kingdom. So
mapping of every piece of sensitive information that you have.
So we thought
long and hard and came up with a
solution for this, which is
what we call the worldless architecture.
So. We use a deterministic
algorithmic approach. We generate these tokens
cry with crypto algorithms that are
now even call them safe
rather than database lookups. This offers infinite
scale for us,
uh, because we aren't limited by the database IO
in this case, and it gives us
the, uh, the nice characteristics of.
Uh, highly performing and you
know, the tokenization operation itself
having very, very low latency in overhead, so it
happens in microseconds.
So this enables real-time use cases
such as fraud detection that were previously
very difficult to achieve with a vaulted approach.
So we kind of anchored our, our tokenization
engine on this, uh,
key, uh, sort of
scale, uh, scaling and artifact.
So, um, as we
built and matured this tokenization, um,
engine within,
uh, Capital One,
we saw the opportunity that,
hey, this is a universal problem. So
how about we think about, you know, helping
other enterprises
by commercializing this technology, um, outside
of Capital One.
So as part of Capital One software
we launched this product called Data World back in April.
Mentioned before
and this is uh designed
with all of these um elements that you
see here so it provides you the same advanced security
models
um it gives you the cloud native architecture
and it gives you lightning fast performance
and it represents an evolution so we did a,
uh, a few added a few bells and whistles
on top of our tokenization engine,
uh, for this to be consumable
outside of Capital One as an enterprise.
So in particular there were some architectural
elements that, um.
Uh, enabled us to do this. This
is where we have a separation of,
uh, duties. So we have a control plane
where you manage all of the metadata, the
policies and keys, etc.
and these sit securely in Capital One's
cloud.
Then there's components that you drop into the,
uh, the customer environments
where the tokenization happens actually. So
what this means is that
it happens within your. Network,
uh, your data never leaves that
environment and comes into the Capital One plane. Only
the metadata is provided there and
then you keep custody of your data. We
never see your sensitive information. So we
built with all of these, uh, architectural
and other constraints in mind,
um, and then Vinai will walk you through the
product and, um, you know, the
capabilities there and also some of our learnings as
we build this and scale this
over to you. Thanks.
Uh, hi, everybody.
My name is Vinayan Kullaule. Uh, I'm the senior
Distribution engineer at Capital One.
I would like to take, uh, next few minutes to peel
back the layer of this architecture at a very
high level.
Uh, as you can see, uh, Data Bolt
operates,
uh, on a hybrid deployment model, which
is designed specifically for the
security and resiliency.
On the left side of your screen,
you see a control plane.
That control plane is deployed within
Capital One software's cloud environment.
It handles the management traffic. Uh,
by management traffic, I mean,
The configuration and the access policies,
uh, and it also serves artifacts
like SDKs,
uh,
your documentations as well.
Uh, this is the place where you go
and configure your SSO,
uh, this is the place where you go and
see your audit, uh, analytics dashboards
as well.
Uh, on the right, uh, you
see a data plane. This is our, uh,
core engine.
This entirely runs, uh,
within your ecosystem as
you mentioned. So.
Every operation is, uh,
is within its its own memory. That
means, uh, this
sensitive data is not going
outside of that process and your
network boundary as well.
This data never reaches our control
plane, so you can be very sure that,
uh, Capital One does not have access to your data.
And this data plan can run
in, uh, in your AWS
VPC
on uh the cloud or
even on on-prem data center as well.
Uh. The critical part,
uh, that I talked about is
all these tokenization detoxation operations
are happening
within the memory. That means
we can do these operations very
fast. You
don't have to
basically do a database lookup as uh Srikan
mentioned earlier.
The other thing that I would like to talk about
is, uh,
I get, uh,
asked a lot, what happens if control plane
goes down?
Uh,
don't worry, we built this for, uh, resiliency.
When the data plane boots up, uh, it
basically
establishes a secure channel with the
control plane
to fetch its configuration and the cryptographic
material, uh, and we take this communication
path very seriously.
Uh, we don't want anybody
to save this traffic and decrypt
later, so, uh, we
use
a NIST approved post quantum algorithm,
uh, on top of regular TLS to secure
this traffic.
Once initialized, uh, this data plane,
uh, caches this information in memory and
continues its its operation. So,
in the event the control plane,
uh, is unreachable, uh, the airplane
can continue its operations autonomously.
Your workload will continue running
without a hiccup even if control panel is not available.
This share nothing runtime approach
ensures that our availability issues, uh,
will never become
your availability issues.
Uh, let's go a little deeper,
uh, on the benefits and
the characters of a data volt.
Uh, Shikan already alluded to the fact
that we use a vaultless architecture.
Uh, in a traditional, uh, vaulted architecture,
you have a massive, uh, central vault.
And uh you store with mapping
between uh your sensitive data and
the token in that pot.
It, it works for the small data sets,
but, uh, when you scale it to the uh
enterprise like bank,
uh, it quickly becomes a bottleneck,
uh, and a massive cost center as
well, uh, and Shik can already
mentioned about the security issues that it brings.
That's why, uh, we chose Waltless
architecture for Data bolt.
DataW uses deterministic
and format-preserving algorithms.
We don't store the mapping, we compare that
mathematically.
And since there is no, uh,
database look up, I've uh repeated this this
many times,
uh, we, we can offer
a single load digit millisecond
latency for this operation.
So, uh, you can scale infinitely.
Uh, you don't,
if, if you need a high throughput, you just need to spin up
more, uh, data blend parts and you
get that, uh, for free.
Now regarding security,
uh, being from Capital One, we are
very paranoid about the security,
uh, in our inter interim implementation,
we assume that the host is
compromised.
Uh, that's the reason we have employed
advanced memory techniques to safeguard
this cryptographic material in memory as well.
These, uh, keys which are in memory
are scrambled.
In such a way that uh if the bad actor
gets access to the host and it dumps
the memory, they will not be able to extract
the keys from the dump as well. It will
be practically infeasible and
we carried
this, uh, these security measures to
Datavolt as well.
Uh, we also support, uh, tokenization
on right, uh, via our SDKs,
uh, which can, uh, seamlessly
integrate with your code,
uh, in the platform like Snowflake, Data
bricks,
uh, and for monitoring, uh,
we use Otel.
That means, uh, our customers don't
have to use,
they can use their, uh, existing monitoring tools,
uh, to monitor data bolt.
Moving on
Uh, in our experience,
uh, for most enterprise, uh,
organizations, analytics is the first
use case for tokenization.
The data dilemma that Shikan talked about
is the most acute here.
Uh, you have data scientists, analysis,
uh, analysts,
uh, that want, uh, uh,
those, uh, they want access,
access to, uh, high fidelity production data
to, um, uh, build models
to run reports.
But you cannot give them, uh, access to raw
PII data.
Uh, historically, uh,
organizations have used masking,
but, uh, masking is just, uh, they
just replace the data with asterisk
that destroys the data utility.
You can't join table on a masked
column. Our
blueprint is very simple land
your data tokenized.
Whether it's S3,
Redshift,
Dabolt, or Snowflake,
use the Dabolt SDKs in your retail
pipeline
to tokenize the data the moment it enters
your analytic environment.
This, uh, gives you two things. First,
security at rest.
So, uh, let's say if someone
incorrectly configures your SD
bucket,
uh, that results in a data breach
leaking your data.
Uh, they get just the, uh,
access to the tokens, not the actual data.
And in fact, uh, for our internal implementation,
uh,
we had this issue and, uh, our
internal recognition saved us, uh, saved our
face because, uh, we had the data
tokenized in that S3 bucket.
The second is the granular access
with uh data address being
tokenized, you can implement
on the fly detokenization
for reads for the authorized users so
that only authorized users can get access to
your raw plane data and your data
is secured.
So, uh, let's look at the concrete implementation
of this pattern using Amazon Redshift. Uh,
this is from uh one of our earlier cust uh,
early customers.
They needed to expand access,
uh, uh,
to their data warehouses,
uh, to all analysis,
uh, but they wanted to
make sure that the raw PII
is, uh, accessed
by a select few analyst.
So, uh, here is how they set it up.
They deployed the, uh, data dataplane
in private submit of the AWS
account, uh,
in the existing AKS cluster.
For the execution flow, they used,
Red shifts, uh, masking policies
and UDF features, uh,
when an analyst,
uh, tries to run a query like Flickstar
from customer,
uh, the red shift invokes this UDF,
uh, for the sensitive columns.
And this UDF triggers a data
bolt to connect to lambda.
This lambda act as a breach, bridge
to the uh data bolt data plane.
This lambda authentic authenticates
the call using uh IM policies,
uh, and then passes the call
to the data plane uh to get the actual
value for the token. Data plane
consults its uh predefined
access policies, and if,
uh, the authorization is correct,
uh, it will return the actual value, otherwise
it will return the same token back.
The result,
uh, the analyst, uh, the analyst
continue using
their standard SQL.
They don't have to worry about the heavy, uh,
security,
um,
lifting that goes in the background.
Uh,
one thing I would like to also note
here that we're also working on a lambda
native data plan
that will remove the need to,
uh, run
the Cuban Native cluster in the AWS environment
for the use cases like this.
OK. Uh, so
now
analytics is the immediate need,
but, uh, the new frontier is obviously
the AI workloads.
Uh, interestingly, the architecture I just
described, uh, applies
almost identically to, uh,
AI workloads as well.
Just that the value proposition shifts
slightly.
In analytics
Uh, you, you may need to see the
real data again,
but uh for the AI workload, you
almost never do.
If you train a model on mass data,
uh, I think, uh, she can went over
this, uh, the model
learns nothing because it's just a string of asterisks.
But with tokenization,
the, uh, feature set is preserved.
Like data world preserves
length and format, so your SSN
is 99 characters long.
Your tokenized email
has, uh, that at the rate symbol and
domain in the token as well.
This means, uh, you can train your small
language model or fine tune your
large language model on fully tokenized
data set.
The model can learn the patterns like, uh,
people with, uh, X zip code
tend to buy a product Y,
like, uh, this use cases
without ever
absorbing the
actual PII into its model weights.
This also effectively eliminates the
model inversion attacks. Uh, these
attacks are basically trying to extract
the original data, uh,
from the model.
This is what the pipelines look like, looks
like in AWS. It's very straightforward.
You have your raw data in S3.
Uh, you can use Glue data catalog
to tag sensitive, uh, columns.
Uh, then Data bolt can ingest this,
uh, metadata,
uh, and it can create a
tokenized replica of this data set.
Then you can, uh, point your SageMaker
training pipeline to this tokenized replica,
uh. The result that
you get is the
high-quality model that is
already compliant
because it never saw the sensitive
data. OK.
Uh, finally, let's talk about
the in-demand use case that is G applications.
Gene applications requires proactive as well as reactive
controls.
Uh, when you deploy chatbot or chatbot-like,
uh, application,
you, you're opening up a new interface to
your data.
Uh, and users are unpredictable. They
can always enter a sensitive
information in, in, in their prompt.
You cannot rely only
on the safety training uh
of the model for that.
If you rely on that, that means you're taking a risk.
Also, uh, there are sometimes legitimate
need for the downstream application to reference
what user, uh, has in the
original prompt. So you might need
access to what user have entered.
So for use cases like this, uh,
we recommend sandwich approached,
uh, first pre-processing, uh, you
tokenize your sensitive data
before it leaves your environment,
then post-processing, when you get the, uh, response
back from the model, detokenize and
return it to the downstream applications.
Uh, this slides.
It illustrate that flow,
um.
If you see in the middle, there is an orchestration
service.
Uh, it acts like a traffic cop.
Uh, it receives the user
input.
Uh, it calls scanner to detect
to see if there are any sensitive elements in
that input. Uh, if it's found,
uh, it will call.
Data bowl to tokenize that information and
then uh it will replace
the sensory information with tokens and then construct
the prompt again and then that prompt
gets sent to uh like Bedrock
uh uh any LLM hosted in the bedrock
uh and after receiving the
response from the LLM
uh if it has sensitive
elements, uh, it will again, uh,
detokenize and then send back the
clear answer to the application or user.
This keeps PII completely invisible
to the model provider. Uh, this also
solves your data residency and privacy
concerns with public LLMs.
OK, uh,
to wrap up, uh, whether it's for
like traditional analytics or the emerging,
uh, AI workloads,
vaultless tokenization ensures you
stay compliant
without slowing down your innovation
velocity, and Data bolt can help
you in that space.
Uh, thank you for your time. I'll hand it back to Shrikan
to cover the key takeaways.
Right, thanks, Vinai. All right, so,
um,
we have
3 key takeaways here that we talked
about. The first part is how do you unlock
your data?
So addressing this whole
issue with this data dilemma that we saw
before where you're balancing the,
uh, utility value of that or
information value of the data
along with the security risk that
it poses. So how do we do that? And then
we identified and showed how
tokenization can help you as one of the strategies
to help you prepare for that.
Um, then the second piece that we talked about
is around the architectures, the cloud
native architectures
designed for the scale,
performance, latency needs, uh,
of a large enterprise with like, you know, uh,
petabytes of data that we have in the cloud.
So, uh, some of the characteristics that we
saw that that helped us, uh, around implementing
these as a vaultless federated
architecture
and then also providing, uh, you
know, using the native services on AWS to enhance
some of these for the scalability side.
Uh, the third key takeaway here is that we
always want to build this as, uh, defense
in depth sort of layers,
so tokenization can be used as one
of those layers, as, as, uh, when I
mentioned, as a data centric guardrail, for, for
example, that gives you these proactive and reactive
controls,
um, and then gives you the ability to,
um,
uh, use your
data responsibly and safely
without worrying about the risk that it poses.
So you can go from.
You know, blocking your AI
use cases due to the risk
to enabling those with
confidence with, with the data protection
built in through these layers.
So, these are the, the key sort of
learnings that we wanted to share with, with you,
um, and also kind of
talk you through this journey so that, um,
you can use this in, in your, uh, day
to day challenges that you see with your enterprise
data. So we'll,
uh,
stop here for, uh, the presentation side of
the house. We have a couple of, uh, call
to action here, so please do visit our booth,
um, and then you will see,
um, on the chairs,
uh, the air tag holder, so
you can go and, uh, collect the air tags from,
uh, our booth.
So we welcome you to come in. Uh, see us
there then we'll show you
a demo of data bolt in action.
Uh, we also have an upcoming webinar where we,
uh, uh,
where we talk about the study that we alluded to here,
uh, where we looked at training
the models on mass data,
the clear data as well as tokenized data,
and we'll share some of the results, uh, that's
upcoming, uh, with PWC
on the 12th,
um, essentially.
These are, uh,
key next steps in terms of how we
want to proceed with this, and we'd love to, um,
kind of get your feedback and questions. Uh, we
have a few minutes left here, so
we'll, we'll pause here and take questions.
Thank you. students.